have you been surprised by evolution
well I think one of the things that's
really surprised me is just how long
this experiments gone on when I
originally started it I expected it to
run for maybe a year or longer and now
here we are almost 30 years later but
within the experiment itself there been
a lot of surprises one of the most
exciting to me has been the fact that we
see that even after all this time in a
constant environment the bacteria are
continuing to evolve and adapt it's as
though there's really no limit to
evolution and that's quite different
from what it what I imagined when I
started the experiment another thing
that's gotten a lot of attention is one
of our 12 populations has gone off and
evolved this new ability to grow on
citrate it's gone off in this new
direction that none of the other
populations have gone and that other
ecoli out in nature are unable to do so
those are a couple of the big surprises
within the experiment and I think they
show that just certain when we stop and
think about evolution and billions of
years over which it's happened and the
vast scale of our planet evolution is
just constantly generating a lot of
exciting new surprises